all right everybody good
yes is that a yes all right good evening
i'm lieutenant ray spencer i'm the
homicide lieutenant with the las vegas
metropolitan police department
i'm out here this evening to give you a
brief on a homicide investigation that
we are conducting
in the 3400 block of center avenue which
is a residential neighborhood
near the intersections of palm and
charleston
the details that i have right now are
extremely preliminary
but at around 6 30 p.m tonight
metro police received a 9-1 call of a
male who had been
shot directly behind me at a four-plex
apartment complex
medical personnel and police arrived on
scene and rendered aid
however that male was transported to umc
trauma where he was later pronounced
deceased
what we have learned is that the victim
who is a white male
in his early 30s was to the rear
of the apartment building with another
female at some point
an unknown black or light-skinned
hispanic male
had approached the male and female and
multiple shots were fired after the
shooting occurred the mail then fled on
foot
and we are urging anyone who has any
information to please reach out to crime
stoppers
or you can call knight i'm sorry you can
call 311 or reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
again your information can remain
completely anonymous and there is reward
money available
so again still very early on in the
investigation we're still trying to
determine
why the male and the female were behind
the complex
and what led up to the actual shooting
but again
early on i'll take a couple questions if
you haven't uh there were two
individuals at the commercial complex
across the street to mention to us
that there had been fighting that they
had seen close around six is there
anything that
um confirms those reports of fighting
earlier in the day
no there's nothing at this point that
shows that fighting earlier in the day
is related but again
i stress we're very early on in this
investigation so
once we get through some more interviews
the details could change
as we know them there were a lot of
people that seemed kind of shaken up by
this happening
right next to their house you know what
would be your message to them with
something like this scary happening in
their neighborhood
well you know anytime something like
this would happen i just
you know urge people to stay inside call
the police report the incident
and just be a good witness and that's
why i urge any of your viewers to please
reach out to crime stoppers
and help us solve this case
and again just any information they have
would be
very valuable at this point do you have
a number of which homicide this is for
this year
i don't know the numbers specifically no
um is there anything you would like to
say
to the effective homicides uh happening
in this neighborhood
uh that the amount that we're at this
year or anything with that effect
no i don't right now i'm gonna we'll
stick to the specifics of this homicide
investigation
one second i'm sorry did you say the
victim was a white male in his 30s
yeah the victim is a white male in his
early 30s and you said you didn't know
if the suspect needed a victim or not
correct we don't know at this point we
do know the male approached him while
they were both on foot but
that's all we know at this point all
right thank you guys
i'm so sorry we missed the very
beginning with a technical problem could
you give your first statement again